l a tutti ragazzi non chiedetevi perché
ciò l'armadio aperto ma sto facendo una
valigia ma io mentre faccio le valigie
faccio anche i video perché sono tutto
professionale siamo tornati ragazzi sul
videogioco quello player a non battere
ground son riuscito a dirlo incredibile
buona visione
cioè stiamo partendo tutti concentrati
nel monumento cordova in questo gioco è
vero con di tua madre [ __ ] al mio 3 1 2
3 38 quello tutte giù c'è una miniera
c'è una segheria sta arrivando gente un
botto di gente occhio
ho trovato tre oddio corre corre corre
che ci sono tutti fuggiti di lama donne
qua becco a rete normale giocato un po
con elmetto io devo vedere quanto
funziona e lo sparo basta allora io l'ho
scarpe una pentola abbiamo vinto ho
trovato una pentola cazzo se ci sono
corpi qua qua ci sono gli amici sono
capire pompa che ho prese via ai e dai
chiude dentro ho capito se mi conviene
più il colpo singolo colpo raffica
aspetta che te sto mai fermo e vabbè
scherzava la madonna tronto che cosa fa
beneficio a pompa io corra con la
padella io tutto sono carlo cracco io io
vinco questo gioco che sono forte
portiamo l'italia ad in testa e questi
videogiochi siamo troppo brave qua c'è
un villaggio non faccio perché faccio io
che sono tutto tutto snello toglie che
sono tutto snello come hai fatto
ma dove i deficienti piace un altro
pompa qua mi che ieri non ho mai a mi
sparano a iaia moio dove chi e dove chi
cosa quando erano più vita ma chi è ma
chi è che sta sparando c'è qualcuno che
sparava non capito chi è comunque se
prendi due volte con il mio col tasto
destro su finirà col mio metalli
è vero è vero
occhio arriva verso di wye river si
rivolge cazzo telefono moto dove è fuori
dall entrata e ci esci che ci sono gli
sci e sci che lo ammazzo corri fuori
dietro dietro dietro dietro a dietro
intende via ma dietro dietro di me non
dietro di lui porca eva perché sta
divorando una bottiglia d'acqua pennello
io a spetta a lui quando beve mi piazzo
sente tutto il pre senti che roba sta
bevendo in questo momento invece ti
rendi conto
non la sta versando del rubinetto sta
bevendo c'è che dire è vero ci abbiamo
un altro in gruppo a caso il cazzo eh
vabbè lo lasciamo lo ammazziamo subito
no lo lasciamo lì ci divertiva a parte
calare alla reattività di mia nonna però
lo guardava da gorno amarezza vagando
magari adesso c'è tutta la pittura di
guerra in faccia adesso ci buttiamo a
puccini chi guarda indietro e bellissimo
è vero è vero dietro era la gente
continua a volare ce l'ha e roque caga
persone tutte quarta lì che casino è io
proporrei 321 adesso è quanto cazzo
sceso incidente che uscita proprio qua
porca eva lercia da più amato più avanti
più avanti anche kg e con dolore quanto
secondo lui conviene che viene da noi se
riesci si sta correndo
magari uno tutto tutto arabo ti fa e lo
fa gli inglesi velino
farle bene io ve lo dico già sono sicuro
ma sicuro che schiatto internet incontro
lo ripeto non è perché c'è già intera
perché sono vicino a casa ci ho trovato
una macchina non è vero davvero si però
non riuscirò mai a prendere io ti amo
mentre il ragazzo si andranno funziona
peccato peso non funziona vengo verdello
lì ho trovato un'arma grazie a dio
sparano ero io ero io bastardo dai è
vero però io avremo tutte le armi volta
che lo stesso kg è morto
peccato mi spiace è morto con onore con
una corrente non esce da quella casa di
me e ci sono le cose qua a cagare e due
le cose ma riesce una c'è una vocina da
alcuni perché uno che si lamento aspetta
facessi vedere tutti i tipi ma deve
regnare tanto non sapranno mai chi l'ha
detto di fatto non puoi neanche se
previamente non so chi è una scimmia che
di veloce però sul lago stai andando tu
ma è stata nessuna città questa cosa è
certa se magari io vado prima sulle
casette qua perché mica go addosso bravi
che possiamo giocare insieme
si vabbè ho capito ma scendi da qualche
può vendere in mezzo alla città fondeva
moscova venanzio disco trovare un'arma
primi spari non faccio a 1000 premio
toulouse e aprendo io pioggia tutte le
armi per chi esce
ma porca [ __ ] ma che conosco storiche
cazzo esco
vorrei che ci voglio anche io a dire
fare vista per ammazzare
non posso restanti è ormai è come facevo
devo prendere l'arma ricaricare non
avete capito stavo arma in mano tanto mi
ha quasi ucciso con l'arma aveva tra
l'altro ha poi anche giovedì a ti sei
messo in un angolo
ma dai ma sto cercando che cassano il
merito dal direttore l'astag beatles e
scappa mai bloccato non riuscivo a
ottenere lo ricorda in termini chiaro
chi balboa all'angolino spesso ti sia un
problema sempre mm orca è diciamo che
nella militari bass previsto tutto
questo che su sanità quanta gente ma che
tu spari sei scemo porco questo spara
poveri a tutti droghi assidai rischiamo
tanto danni morti questo picchiarlo
tutti lo piccolo ai una libertà
ciao amici sono una persona tutta
pacifica aiutami a non è vero che vi fa
io e io no bellissimo
ma ho aperto una stanza vuota va molto
bene tutto bene
c'è una macchina lorica dove dietro di
te
guido guido turni così può guidare noi e
sembra tutto bello
tanto che ho visto fermo c'è una
macchina come i cani guardano il cibo o
una macchina mi guardo lo guardo fermo
esorcizzato tutto emozionato ho detto
ciò che con le macchine matrice la festa
a sorpresa guarda mappa ahi ahi e via
via via via via via via forti forti
corri corri
oggi occorre la barca varcavano marika
da migliaia ruota michael fair miss
quanto lento notare lo scontro morti
dopo è finito pensate che ridere che non
abbiamo mai trovato una cazzo di
macchina vi ho tratto una barca primo
mezzi come così non funziona
li ho visti pucciare con le barche erano
capito f getting the boat madonna non
sai neanche leggere vai parti tutto
evitando piede sbagliato io lei a praga
è stato bruttissimo sono comunque ancora
troppo forte ma ora che ci segue quella
roba là c'è una roba rossa in mezzo si
vabbè ma come cazzo che prendiamo in
acqua riuscendo 321 esce esci prendi e
questo è finito veloce ho fatto queste
cose gta un sacco di volte veloce che ci
inculano io continuiamo avermi nel caso
ma risolto grazie abbiamo cecchino ai
c'è partita e che partita sta facendo
molto poco eccitante e volevo fare una
cosa più [ __ ] io rifarei tutto un po
moscio questo ragazzo che facciamo noi
scendiamo dentro che cazzo stiamo sipro
circa 1o tantissimo
siamo arrivati da dietro dove in teoria
doveva arrivare nessuno quindi perfetto
ma non si è fermata si è fermata una più
benzina
che culo si è fermata precisa dove si
dovrà fermare madama chi cuore questa
sera va in mezzo al mare così ti
ammazzano di botte te lo dico io sono
curioso di vedere come la zona militare
sarei veramente troppo curioso di vedere
cosa faceva troppo male lo so e moriremo
prima però la ragazza è una macchina mi
sa che troviamo pure la macchina si va
beh dobbiamo vincere un raga ragazzi si
generoso dio aspetto raga partiamo che
il tempo e il tempo non aspetta nessuno
che un muro che mi sta fermando
non ce la fa ti ammazzo a tutti e due
gli ambiti come i bambini e bambine e
bambini in gita che cosa fa quello esse
prenderanno la tradizionale esce o più
veicoli south of gassman coma cosa non
abbiamo un sacco
infatti non c'è più ban è vero qual è la
resistenza a parametri che non fa
scendere io sono sulla montagna venitemi
a prendere che cecchino non so come
cazzo devi fare con la benzina lasciando
tantissima donna madonna quanto laga e
quindi è un fattore di difficoltà
arrivati all'aquila
chi è come chi è stato dove quando
aiutami
non lo so mi date informazioni vai e vai
nordovest scappa nord onlus tipo a
rischio tantissimo stanno qua però la dc
se con rendimento nullo è appunto o mag
e così ho trovato un credo nel deserto
bachi ciao amici vado io ciao ci vediamo
in un altro il video sequestrava dori
sul 3 milioni l'anno 3 milioni l'anno
contro tutti i bug i fortissimi
mamma mia quanto sono bello guarda lo
investo non ho investito per me l'ha
proprio ma neanche il soldato vicino ai
hanno preso non sono affatto cosa
ahia ahia 26 11 deputati che vorrei
vedermi le mutandine
ok questo che come sono fuori sepolto
nella terra con le mutande fuori
bellissimo e quindi ragazzi questa è
stata la partita
perdonatemi devo andare ad ammazzare una
persona
quindi ragazzi sia video consente
piaciuto al momento mi piace anche vari
come dire la descrizione saras dove si
insegna che ci vediamo
fate un prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]